we have a history of comedy in this
country that is hard to reckon with now
I like to say that I'm grandfathered in
because I was on [__] mad tv in the
90s and the 2000s there if you want to
cancel me just watch Mad TV and then you
know I'm [__] do you think at a
certain point we'll be able to have
character where everybody can be
whatever they at some point it should be
able to be that way I think that I think
that the shit's being stretched back so
far now
it's like this I feel like we're all in
this weird it's like I said these things
happen every 30 years with regard to you
know social
you know just the the um the sand at the
bottom of the sea getting mixed up and
before the Smoke Clears the social
upheaval that seems to happen every 30
years we are in the middle of it now
we're in a pivotal point in in our
country and in our culture and it's my
hope that everyone that what we'll be
left with is equality for everybody and
if we can actually and again I don't
not to sound negative but I don't think
it's possible as much as I would like to
see
but I'm Canadian I'm I'm we have our
problems there for sure a lot of uh a
lot of crimes against the indigenous
First Nations people of of Canada which
is just absolutely [__] tragic we
have our problems there with other race
relations also as well but um I'm from
Canada where at least the kind of the
the curriculum as a kid you know it was
way more Multicultural than it is here I
got here and I was like wow it's really
[__] segregated seriously oh we had a
scratch and sniff history book I
remember for a while
see and Italian scratch and sniff would
have been [__] great no racism there
kids would have worn that out just
smelling [__] Beefaroni or whatever
you'd put in an American textbook I hope
with regard to Comedy the comedy is just
[__] comedy We Gotta Laugh Gallo's
humor is really important yeah and if
we're treating each other well and
there's uh you know equality socially
and everyone can laugh because everyone
feels good about where they are in life
and we are a society that takes care of
one another and uh I mean again I'm from
Canada where there's socialized medicine
it's pretty [__] good and if you're
not living in a [__] world where
you're allowed to walk around and
[__] eat berries and kick a chicken
against a tree and you know do whatever
you want and just build a [__] house
without any code or anything like that
if we're going to live in a society
where you're born into a [__] system
system needs to take care of everybody
period and it ain't [__] happening
and that's going to be my platform but
if that's the case and we can achieve
something like that again I do not think
it's possible at all we're [__] [__]
let me just put that in there I ain't
running for office but if we can do that
then we can start to laugh at absolutely
everything again right now people are
not wanting to laugh at [__] and they
have every right not to laugh at [__]
because stuff is [__] dire so you
can't go on Mad TV and make fun of
absolutely everybody although you know
we had Aries Spears Deborah Wilson Phil
Lamar but it was funny at the time
hilarious makes me [__] laugh now
those people that I learned so much
about the black culture and laughing you
know with them and also growing up most
people still just want to laugh they
don't yes they really care I think so
but I think it's it's just like
it's like you know it's like
No One's Gonna let themselves [__]
laugh you know what I mean now that's
interesting do we let ourselves laugh no
but we keep ourselves from yeah we all
get on this alert kind of where it's
like don't point at me don't offend me
you know I mean I got upset over the
panda over like uh during the like last
big election thing because the only
people that people were making fun of
was poor white people right and it was
like what the [__] did we do it's like
yeah poor white people they didn't even
like we didn't do it like
like we didn't do rate like I'm sure
that writ wealthier white people
probably own slaves I don't know any
nobody I knew how to they didn't I don't
think they ever had a slave you know or
they're they might have but I couldn't
imagine it dude but it's socially it's
just if you look at it generally totally
socially acceptable to make fun of poor
white white people right in 2020. right
totally totally acceptable and it and
and none of it should be acceptable
unfortunately or fortunately things do
need to be mixed up a bit and you need
and
you know I always I use the example of
in 2020 learning about Juneteenth yeah I
was like I didn't [__] uh I was
telling black friends something never
heard of the [__] Juneteenth I don't
know what the [__] that is what is that
I had no clue most of my black friends
have no idea what it is until it came
out what's that too yeah they kind of
launched it a few years ago I feel like
I mean I know they didn't but it's like
if you'd have asked any black kid and
where I'm from what Juneteenth was it I
have no [__] clue yeah no but it's
it's interesting what you're saying
about like it's like oh yeah it's easy
to make fun of [__] you know poor
white people I feel like that's another
symptom of of the social sort of again
the the silt at the bottom of the ocean
getting uh getting um getting smoked up
do you think we as a Comedians and we
have to be the ones to kind of like see
where the thing is at then you know I
think yes I think you know in in your
Avenue with with podcasting and stand up
and sort of you know I'm primarily an
actor but I love doing weird [__] on the
internet and doing podcasting and stuff
and also you know if I can be
responsible for any sort of weird
creative uh [__] if I ever get to you
know work on things and make stuff it's
it is up to us but it is also it's quite
a responsibility because we're it's this
bizarre currency of quote-unquote
cancellation which some people don't
even think exists which is to me it's
weird it's like well you just said
cancellation that means that it's a word
right it exists
um and I think that you you have to be
you have to be uh
a brave comedian to kind of look it's
not fun to just go out there and go I
want things to be the way they used to
be in the 90s that to me to me
personally as a comedy fan to me that's
hack yeah it's like to not push [__]
[__] forward great comedians have a
complete like I'm sure you you love them
I love George Carlin right like just
come on that that guy was always years
ahead of his time and always
shot right down the middle you knew
exactly what he was thinking and he
represented himself completely honestly
I think that
um you know comedians who who are being
100 honest and not just trying to you
know be shocking for shocking sake or
say I should be allowed to say this
because I said it in 1995. you know I
think audiences today that's fine but
your audience is going to be awfully
specialized if you just want to be a
prick about things and say everyone
should laugh at these things that
currently people are uh sensitive about
and for good reason if you can find new
things to laugh about there are new
things to laugh about in our
completely [__] bizarre social
climate yeah it's [__] bizarre you
just said I got black friends who grew
up with that wouldn't have known
Juneteenth that's a joke you couldn't
say in 1998 because absolutely nobody
knew what the [__] you were talking
about with Juneteenth yeah but 2020 was
a really uh was such a
you know a Rife year of of uh you know
with the pandemic and and and and and
the you know the social oh yeah it got
black black lives matter yeah it wasn't
it was wild yeah yeah yeah so it's like
now I think you
I think you can uh but you got to be
smart about it and I'm not I'm not smart
about it I don't I'm not saying that's
me at all and I'm not yeah I've never
been yeah but but I I do think that
I think that people will start to chill
out a little bit because socially what
happens in my opinion mine is just my
opinion with these waves is that people
all get [__] tired you know at the
end of the day we just want to most
people just want the same [__] yeah they
want to be able to take care of their
families they want to have something
nice for dinner they want to know that
they're safe at home they want to know
that if they go to the wrong [__]
door they're not going to get shot in
the face uh the horrible [__] that's
happening right now because everyone is
so
wound up and charged up it's truly
[__] scary people are scared man I
realized the other day I'm walking up to
a car I did and it was it wasn't my car
I get right by the door handle I realize
it wasn't my car it looked just like my
car there's somebody sitting in that car
and I'm like
oh my God that person could [__]
shoot me right now yeah and I wouldn't
even think it was crazy because that's
just where the fear level is at it's
like all these POV videos of all this
fear
um it's it's interesting man it's a it's
a it's a it's a fairy time out there I
and I'm never afraid of anything because
I look like a gigantic football coach
cop and I drive a a Tahoe so I could
yeah I could technically be a park
ranger uh we need that Alex Jones back
though just just in general I think we
need him you know I would love to see
him do and that's what I thought he was
going to get into was like a regular
guy's job after he had the big uh
lawsuit against him was um manager in
like a Denny's or something manager and
like an IHOP yeah I got you got to get
the moons over my they're making the
moons over Miami gay
I'm a humanist let me tell you something
about these people out here eating
mozzarella sticks
I've eaten mozzarella sticks of Bohemian
Grove it was invented by Mark Twain uh
just a rich and originally it was just a
a place for these globalist uh people to
it was uh actually a lot of closeted uh
homosexual activity happening there
mostly by Republicans but Democrats took
it over and uh John F Kennedy Bobby
Kennedy Jr Bobby Kennedy uh they went
out to Bohemian Grove you could still go
there to Northern California and they're
deep in the forest wearing robes like
Druids
yeah what do you want uh how would you
like your eggs
you want white toast we toast I hate
this uniform ah just always ripping off
his [__] polo shirt
you want to see my name
you know and these people are they're
reptiles I've seen it up close they
don't have skin like you and me I've
been up close I've been next to Nancy
Pelosi
Hillary Clinton these people are not
human they're interdimensional beings
they come in they open wrens in the uh
in the fabric of time and space and they
walk through
I'm gonna wanna see it
everybody wants the same thing at the
end of the day they just want to be able
to watch uh you know sit down
eat their Frijoles with their family
watch white porn with their family
all right
and watch this fool on TBS
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one